the Joe Rogan experience if anybody
sounded the alarm
that all this madness was gonna come to
fruition in the real world it's you sir
you were you were the guy like you were
the one who's saying this is what's
happening at Evergreen and if you don't
know go google it
Bret Weinstein evergreen and now it
spills out into the real world just like
I said it was gonna you did I didn't I
did I said it in several different
places and pretty clearly you know it
could have been a tiny bit more
precision but I was highly accurate you
are highly accurate and often maligned
and mocked yeah people didn't think it
was a big deal they think you were much
ado about nothing you're making a big
deal about some kids that are voicing
their opinions on things but what you
recognized early on was that there was
an authoritarian aspect of it a forced
compliance aspect of it that's very
dangerous yeah it's all about force and
you know I've started to get calls in
the last week or two the people who who
mocked me and others including you for
making too much of what appeared to be
college kids going wild on college
campuses some of them have started to
call and say I got it wrong what do we
do now and actually I I appreciate those
those calls in those contacts because
really that is the question in some ways
you do now to pull it back yeah the
genie back in the bottle or is Douglas
Murray says how do you put the brakes on
this thing how do you put the brakes on
this thing indeed well I have to tell
you I'm not optimistic I think that this
is actually the people who are catching
up to the fact that Evergreen has now
spilled over into the world
I have not caught up to the fact that
this is unstoppable at this point with
the current configuration the absence of
leadership is going to prevent us from
doing what we should do and that means
that the next set of predictions are far
more dire what is your next set of
predictions well I would say we are
headed for a collision course with with
history I mean we're really staring
many scenarios that end in some kind of
civil war and while I do think it is
still possible to avert that outcome I
don't know the name of the force that
gets in its way that's it's really
troubling what do you think these kids
want not just kids what do you what do
you think the people that are
facilitating chaos what do you think
they want well I think there's some
danger in casting them as one thing
because I think we have several things
fused together and that until you
understand what has joined forces with
what you're not gonna there's no way to
answer the question all right let's
break it down okay so one thing that
we're seeing is and we really have to
take this back a number of years to
understand why it happened but we are
seeing occupy 2.0 hmm now I participated
in Occupy originally occupy made a lot
of sense it was a complaint about the
tarp program and too big to fail and the
fact that the American public was not
protected when those who had created the
financial collapse were and that was a
legitimate gripe and it was also a
legitimate gripe at the beginning of the
Tea Party movement occupy then morphed
into a an anarchist movement that was
just simply hostile to civilization and
it became absurd and so when I say this
is occupied 2.0 this is the anarchist
version of Occupy that has now reemerged
and it has fused with black lives matter
which as I've said lots of different
places if black lives matter just simply
meant with those words imply I'd be on
board with that it doesn't it means a
great deal more than that and we're
beginning to see that in the last couple
of weeks what else do you think it means
well let's put it this way for some
reason it means abolish the police which
is possibly the stupidest proposal I
have ever heard and it's not like we
haven't seen what happens when you do
that I don't think that's just a fearful
response to the obvious police brutality
that we saw in Minneapolis what's the
best response we have to do something we
need to defund the police and then ever
like good job great great first step at
least well no it's a dishonest
presentation and I'm concerned that
there as I've also said in many places
the proposals that are coming out of
this movement are quite foolish the
strategy is incredibly smart and so that
is confusing to people because when you
hear folks in the street demanding that
we abolish the police you think well
okay that's never going to happen if it
even started to happen it would be so
complex to make it happen that it can't
possibly be they just need to blow off
some steam nope that's not right the
fact is the police in some places can
effectively be halted in their tracks
and really if there's one most important
lesson out of the whole Evergreen fiasco
it's that the police can be withdrawn
from a situation and chaos takes a
matter of hours to emerge which we are
also seeing in Seattle yeah the
defunding of the police which is
happening in Minneapolis what are they
doing in replacement of the police well
I don't know and I will say the the
thing that is trotted out as the example
that tells us that defund the police
which doesn't really mean do you fund
the police it means abolish the police
we are told that that's safe on the
basis of something like the Camden
example what Camden just did they sort
of broke the police down but then built
up a new version of the police right
yeah they shifted it to a different
jurisdiction and look I'm not arguing
that we don't need massive police reform
and frankly I'd be up for a discussion
of a total rethink of the way we do
policing but the idea that you could
withdraw the police first is absolutely
insane mark Lamont Hill had a very good
point about the guy who was killed what
it was a gentleman's name that was
killed in the drive-in drive-through
fast food place
Rashard said they say his name who was
just drunk and compliant and peaceful
until they were telling him they were
gonna arrest him even said get me an
uber and what his point was it was a
very good point why were the police even
called for that this is a non-violent
person
just happened to be drunk was he doing
something he should have been doing yes
but obviously compliant polite speaking
well just like very reasonably until it
escalated into this tussle and then he
lost his life if they had just had some
sort of a program where they could we're
gonna park your car sir or we'll have
someone drive your car to your house
we're gonna call you an uber or we're
gonna take you home and we're gonna just
write you a ticket and work this out in
court you're not gonna go to jail you
don't have to be arrested you don't to
be handcuffed you're gonna be treated
like a monster you [ __ ] up you made a
mistake but you're not a bad person you
know as a person who's trying to hurt
people the police should be there for
robbers murderers rapists that's that's
what we need the police for and this is
another none of those things this is
just a guy who [ __ ] up and he got
drunk and he and then as they were
speaking to him clear real clear not a
bad guy like the way he's talking to
cops just talking to him very reasonably
even asked for an uber well look I am no
fan of this aggressive style of policing
not a fan of the militarization of the
police I've actually I mean I've had
run-ins with the police I've been hit
twice by cops so it's not going to
happen well one of these is a long story
that goes back to my first research gig
in Jamaica and the other one was I was
participating in a protest I mean I was
very young I was probably 20 and there
was a protest about homelessness in
Berkeley and frankly it happened without
my awareness that there was going to be
a protest but I happened to be nearby
and I was sympathetic and so I joined it
and I was coming down the street with
the protest and the cop hit me with a
with a baton knocked me down
so anyway I'm no fan of this stuff I'm
not defending it but that's not what
this movement is really about and even
if it is to the extent that it is what
this movement is really about it doesn't
deal with the root cause we're dealing
with a symptom and it's not a symptom
that you can treat in isolation well I
had Jocko will link on the podcast on
Monday and he had a great point
obviously Jocko was a Navy SEAL
commander and worked with the Navy SEALs
to create Pro
grams for training and what he said is
that these cops have the the minimal
amount of training it's at the tiniest
amount of training and then they send
them on the street he goes 20 percent of
their time should be spent training 20
percent it should be de-escalation
drills simulation drills educating them
on how to communicate with people in
various situations educating them as how
if one cop is in a confrontation with
someone the next cop should step in and
say let's let's just calm down Mike once
you go go deal with this over there and
I'm gonna handle this and sir let's
let's let's take this from scratch like
let's work let's work this out and that
having higher qualified police officers
better trained police officers more well
better compensated police forces so
they're not taxed out is really the
answer to all this and these people are
there you know nobody wants to be a cop
right now so who's doing this right
who's the new generation from now out
when when people sign up to be a police
officer who's gonna do this this it's a
you have a few that are gonna answer
that call because they feel like it's a
they have a duty but you're gonna have a
lot of people that just they can't get
other jobs and so they choose that and
maybe they're not the cream of the crop
and so that's very bad for people with
guns that tell other people what to do I
hear two things in what you're saying
and one of them I fully agree with the
implication what you just said is that
less funding isn't the solution if
anything more funding is so that we get
better qualified people better training
trained them right we get people who are
better suited to the job in the first
place and then we train them better so
they know what to do and I agree with
that the part that I'm worried about is
that I also I think I hear you grasping
at straws and frankly they're familiar I
hear everybody grasping at straws here
and what I think is not getting said is
that brutal policing is a feature not a
bug alright this is part of a system
that is about something else and to the
extent that I think we can all recognize
that there is something absolutely
organic about the anger that has caused
people to spill into the streets in
large numbers that anger is the result
of a process that does not begin with
policing it begins with
economic phenomena and political
phenomena and one of the things that
spooks me is this movement in part
because it is leaderless and I would
argue rudderless it is not correctly
addressing the actual problem it is
lashing out at things that it can see
it's lashing out in anecdotes but the
only solution here the only proper
solution that actually saves the
Republic is a solution that addresses
the core problem economic despair
communities that are filled with crime
and violence and gangs and the people
that come out of these communities with
very little hope and all the models that
they operate under the what what they
model themselves on is what they see
around them which is all this crime and
they they don't have this sense that
there's a very clear path out of this
well let's um I want to step back to
something that will sound too remote to
be useful but I'm sure it isn't I would
claim that this actually goes back to a
shift in the Democratic Party during the
Clinton administration during the
Clinton administration the Democratic
Party effectively switched it took up
the Republican Party's business model
moving away from defending the interests
of common people as its reason for
gaining power and that created a problem
so during the Clinton administration we
saw the end to aid with family to
families with dependent children we saw
NAFTA we saw basically an abandonment of
the core resin d'etre for the Democratic
Party now the Republican Party at that
point was the party of business but that
doesn't really mean the party of
business what the Republican Party was
was the party of well-established large
businesses which frequently meant as it
was catering to their interests that it
was preventing small businesses from
rising up that would threaten its
constituents now the Democrats took up
this model they went into influence
peddling as well during the Clinton
administration and they became the party
of other businesses so now you have two
parties that are basically dealing with
competing business interests vying for
power but what that does is
excludes the interests of regular folks
and so regular folks have been getting
the shaft ever since nobody is
representing their interests they're
getting wise to it and they're feeling
the effects on the street they are
feeling the system is rigged it's rigged
against them
it's not even evenly rigged against them
so you know in black communities there's
a perception it's specifically rigged
against us and you know what it is but
the way it is is very subtle right it's
not a matter of racism being ubiquitous
you know inside every white head it's
not like that this has very little to do
with modern racism but what it has to do
with is a property of our system so you
know there's a cybernetic principle the
purpose of a system is what it does it
means that don't listen to what somebody
says that the system is for look at what
it accomplishes that's what it's for
and our system basically has two things
that it accomplishes it basically keeps
real change from happening and the
reason it keeps real change from
happening is because people who are
winning in the present system will
continue to win if the system continues
to do what it does and they may lose if
the system changes and starts doing
something else so it creates what I
would argue is a kind of organic
conservatism those with power don't want
change because it threatens them and the
other thing that our system does is it
reproduces present patterns of
distribution into the future and what
that means is racism that has almost
died out is still alive and well in a
sense
because all you have to do is take
people who are born into a neighborhood
that is devoid of opportunity and
continue that pattern if no opportunity
shows up then people who were oppressed
are now going to continue to be
oppressed and so it feels personal but
it isn't it's just reproducing an
existing pattern and a lot of that
emanates from these communities that
have been disenfranchised and
economically distraught from slavery
like literally from that where we're
dealing with the echoes of slavery and
it doesn't get addressed and when people
do bring it up and they start talking
about rep
nation's people roll their eyes and
people go so long ago but the results of
that are still alive today in the South
they're still alive today in many
communities that were redlined
as recently as the 1960s right that's
exactly right and so it we basically
have set ourselves up for a confused
response because there is a subtlety the
fact that ancient races and people who
are dead their racism still haunts us
today through mechanisms of the
reproduction of patterns of distribution
and mind you and people here
distribution they freak out because they
think you're talking about wealth I'm
not talking about wealth and we can talk
about why I wouldn't bother but what
we're talking about is opportunity
opportunity has been hoarded it has been
concentrated in some zip codes and
almost totally excluded from other zip
codes and so you're right the patterns
of slavery moved into Jim Crow and now
they've moved into a phase where they
are very subtly infused in into our
system and so it is causing people to
have the sense that there is an enemy
and it is out to get me when it's not
exactly an enemy that's out to get you
it's a pattern right it's a pattern that
definitely needs to be addressed and so
the natural place would have been the
Democratic Party but the Democratic
Party because it has taken up with big
business is not going to do it even
though it would be a winning political
strategy the Democratic Party is more
interested in serving the political the
economic interests of its actual
constituents than it is serving the
interests of its nominal constituents
and so why are you seeing something that
looks like a communist revolution
beginning in the streets for the natural
reason which is that people are feeling
excluded from from their share and they
are being excluded but this revolution
that is beginning in our streets is no
more coherent or desirable than you know
then maoism and it's going to be brutal
in in the Maoist way or possibly the way
that it unfolded in the French
Revolution or maybe it'll be some you
know unique version and it'll get its
own name
but if we want the Republic to survive
we're gonna have to prevent this from
happening and because it's a leaderless
movement who do you even talk to
who'd be reasonable yeah that's what's
fascinating about it right because it's
emerging not just in America but it's
also in England it's and it's in all
parts of the world people are protesting
and in many ways I think that's it's
probably because loved it or hated
America sort of takes the cultural lead
for the world in a lot of ways when it
comes to movements and particularly art
and and and you know expression and I
see this leaderless movement and it
seems so attractive to young people that
do feel disenfranchised by the system so
I I watch them I mean I've seen so many
videos of these people out there
screaming and cheering and chanting and
they feel like they're a part of
something right and they are right but
what is that thing that they're a part
of like what's the end goal that doesn't
seem to have been really clear like
there's kids out in they were out in
Woodland Hills out there chanting no
justice no peace and I'm like okay what
justice you talking about are you
talking about George Floyd well that in
that case it seems like that guy's gonna
go to jail for the rest of his life and
I don't know if that's justice or not
that police department has been
disbanded I don't know if that's justice
or not but what is justice and what is
peace it's just a slogan but they feel
good saying it no justice no peace but
what I don't know what you're saying but
you feel very passionate about what
you're saying and I think if you pulled
one of those kids aside and said what's
your message and what are you trying to
do I think a lot of them would have
nothing to say and that's what's that's
very concerning to me I'm very concerned
about that because it seems like they're
very enthusiastic and passionate about
an invisible enemy and an enemy that
they can't they can't put on a scale
they can't tangibly describe it in a way
that I understand it completely it just
seems like the structure of things they
feel like is is
unjust it is unfortunately a zombified
collective fighting a boogeyman that
they have invented which again doesn't
mean that their frustration is not about
something very real that does require a
solution but to the extent that these
people have D individuated and they've
become a true mob and they are pushing
policies that make no sense and endanger
us all I mean there is no neighborhood
in the u.s. that is going to be safer
for the absence of the police and it
really doesn't even matter how corrupt
the police are the absence of the police
is going to create a power vacuum and
we're going to get warlords as we're
already seeing in miniature in Seattle
as we already saw at Evergreen yeah so
it's not a coherent proposal but I have
a concern that the reason that this is
leaderless is that something that I
think is unrelated I really think it's
unintentional but there is something
about the way that influence happens in
this era that has taken all of the
would-be leaders and it has trapped them
in the gig economy and so we have a lot
of people who would be in an excellent
position to steer this justifiable anger
at an enemy that is actually worth
attacking to curb the violence and to
make this a a moment of useful and
necessary change I would argue overdue
change
but those people are instead of being
leaders but they are as influencers and
influencers don't have the kind of power
necessary to shape a movement and they
don't have the position to negotiate on
its behalf and this is very dangerous
where do you think this escalates to do
you have a map in your mind of where the
territory is yeah I mean I would say
there are several ways it could go but
unfortunately the dynamics look almost
unresolvable if somebody does not speak
for the movement and with it being
unresolvable you've got a conflict
between rural people and urban people
you have a conflict between blacks and
those who are self declared allies and
ally doesn't really mean ally but foot
soldiers on behalf of this movement and
people who won't go along with it and
what I'm trying to raise people's
awareness of right now is that there's
something in us being raised in the u.s.
there's something in us that thinks that
the Great Leap Forward in China cannot
happen here that what happened in
Cambodia cannot happen here that Nazi
Germany cannot happen right and you know
the Soviet Union couldn't happen here I
don't know what characteristic it is
that people think makes it impossible I
don't think it's impossible I think if
there is a characteristic that makes it
unlikely it is the structure it is the
Constitution which I would argue is
showing its age but nonetheless the
values that America aspires to the
reason that the world does pay attention
to us and still even with all of our
brokenness allows us to lead it that
reason is that the values that were
described were honorable even if they
even if we didn't meet them but what we
aspired to be was great and I you know I
resent Trump's make America great again
because there are populations for whom
it has simply never been great right so
I think that last a in Magga is just a
finger in the eye for people and it was
designed to be but the structure what it
aspires to be as great and heading in
the direction in which it could be great
for everybody is obviously the right
thing to do but what we are now doing
and the thing that troubles me
[Applause]